will you know the advantage of uh
speaking the very last um in a a day
like this is that all of the uh truly
complicated and complex issues have
already been dealt with um and you'll
see uh some recapitulation of many of
the themes that you've heard about
through the day the liability of going
last of course is that pretty much
everything that needed to be said has
been said um I am going to cope with
that by uh trying to give you a slightly
different frame of reference for uh the
work that you've heard today that
involves a kind of uh synthesis a kind
of convergence that Clyde and I realized
that we were coming to uh in that last
uh year of his life and I'd like to just
share that convergence with you uh for
your consideration as a way of uh in
some way making sense of all of these
data um that have been so compellingly
uh presented
today so the the title um that I chose
was uh from science to action Clyde
herzman vision for a more just and
generous World Clyde was um a tremendous
advocate for social justice for uh
generosity on the part of human
societies and it's uh truly an honor to
present a lecture um in his
name so in in my brief remarks this
morning I mentioned that Bob Evans had
uh said that Clyde's philosophy really
could be summarized in seven words which
is uh it doesn't have to be this
way he he would have argued that doesn't
have to be that 14 to 24% of North
American children live in
poverty he would have argued that 10 and
a half million of the world's children
uh having to die from preventable
diseases each year before they're 5
years old doesn't have to
be he would have argued that it is
completely unacceptable that 2 million
children are exploited each year in the
global commercial sex trade and he would
have said that it doesn't have to be
that children from disadvantaged
communities sustain higher levels of
toxic stress virtually every form of
human malady and premature
mortality um it just doesn't have to be
there are things that we can do about uh
each of those so Clyde's work and mine
uh began to uh intermingle and converge
in this decade from 2003 to 2013 I had
the great great Good Fortune of spending
seven years uh at the University of
British Columbia and believe me David I
am not gone I have a footprint securely
planted in Vancouver and and hope I will
uh forever hence so I would like to
argue that that these two sets of Works
uh Clyde's social epidemiology and my
work in uh Developmental Pediatrics uh
resulted in a convergence on a novel
hypothesis which we believed had
implications for population health
and social
policy so let's start with Clyde's work
his work really began and arjan uh this
morning alluded to this work with uh
observations about the Health crisis in
eastern uh Europe in the decades
following the collapse of the Soviet
Union uh The Disappearance of Communism
and the Really the blighted societies
that were left uh in the wake of those
uh political
events this was the kind of uh of uh
Association that he was uh particularly
interested in when he looked at temporal
Trends in male cardiovascular mortality
in eastern versus Western Europe in this
three decades beginning in 19 uh60 what
he noted uh cogently was that in Western
Europe there was this uniform decline in
cardiovascular mortality among men uh
living in the countries of of Western
Europe and this was true for uh 45 to 64
year old men for 65 to 74 year old men
and in each of these uh uh time periods
for both and in contrast to that those
living in uh Eastern Europe had not just
smaller uh declines in cardiovascular
mortality but actually increases in
cardiovascular mortality uh over the
same uh time period here was a
compelling interesting uh natural
experiment that demanded uh an answer
for why this was happening the answer
that uh Clyde came to along with uh
students and trainees and colleagues
like arjin uh was that this had to do
with swift economic and political
transformation with an economic decline
that was happening in Eastern Europe
with increasing disparities in income
distributions and with distrust for
civil
institutions uh a constellation of uh
conditions that sounds remarkably like
the United States now that I think about
it um at the moment um but this was all
then In The Same Spirit as this iconic
work of Michael Marmet and his
colleagues uh in the White Hall studies
of socioeconomic status and health which
as he and others demonstrated earlier
today was this uh clear grad gradient a
step stepwise increase in mortality
rates within the British uh civil
servants uh depending upon the class of
uh of civil service um categorization
that they were in this is a fundamental
observation that has uh transformed the
way that we think about uh social
determinance of Health it is a an
association that is so powerful that we
don't believe any other Association
without first controlling for social
class and yet we never really studied it
as a phenomenon in itself until about 20
30 uh years
ago an interesting thing happened then
in this these early years of Clyde's
career this is a plot of Clyde herzman
papers in referee journals from 1983 to
2013 and first thing I want you to
notice is this colossal increase in uh
scholarly productivity that continued
throughout the 30 years of his academic
life but the interesting thing was that
there was a point in time right here in
1994 uh when he published a paper by the
title The lifelong impact of childhood
experiences a population Health
perspective in datalis in in uh 1994 and
beginning at that point there was this
really exponential increase in the
proportion of his papers uh that were
child oriented um that were that were
focused on uh the uh conditions of
children conditions of childhood and
their implications for not only
concurrent health and development within
childhood but they're long-term
implications as well for uh uh health
and development uh over the life course
so there was this inflection point when
suddenly and if you go back and read uh
these papers that immediately preceded
that there's very little mention of
childhood it's really really quite
interesting uh this sort of
spontaneously generated and suddenly
with this dataless article he is talking
and talking eloquently and profoundly
about the importance uh of Early
Childhood now why would that have
happened well I think these are some of
the things that had caught Clyde's
attention the first was this fundamental
observation of David Barker uh that
appeared um one article was in 1989 in
the Lancet which related uh ha the
hazard ratio for coronary heart disease
uh death rates before age 65 to birth
weight uh obviously decades uh earlier
in the life course and he showed that
children who were born uh underweight uh
and in a graded Association had a
systematically higher rate of
cardiovascular disease and uh actually
coronary heart disease mortality uh than
those who who were born of normal uh
birth weight so the first glimmer of
this implication that something that's
happening in early childhood is having
effects decades later on cardiovascular
risk in the lives of uh these
individuals secondly he was uh
fascinated to find that the gradient
that had been identified in the British
civil servants by Michael Marmet and
others uh was replicated uh clearly in
the uh relationship between
socioeconomic status and child health
within childhood populations so here is
work from Edith Chen uh plotting any
limiting chronic uh pediatric condition
ear disease physical inactivity asthma
and injury as a function of uh
socioeconomic status going from low on
the left side to high uh on the right
side and again the Michael Marmet uh
graded Association not what Clyde would
have called a hockey stick but rather a
linear monotonic Association across the
full range of of socioeconomic uh
status and third he was increasingly
impressed with the evidence for a kind
of biological embedding of societal
influences on child health and
development and he was fond of talking
about how social signal transduction
conducted this kind of archaeology that
began with uh the social and lived
experience of a child that was then
underpinned by uh the neural circuitry
that underpins behavior experience
emotion that was then underpinned by
differences in functioning at the level
of neurons and synapses and that in turn
was underpinned by differences in uh in
genes and uh epigenetic uh modifications
so there was this emerging literature uh
that suggested that childhood
experiences were important not only not
only for childhood but for distant adult
Health that they were biologically
embedded and uh he suddenly really began
to pursue this with all of the Vigor
that Clyde uh was known
for now I want to remind you at this
juncture here uh of this classic uh
truly wonderful paper by Jeffrey rose
that appeared in the international
Journal of epidemiology in
1985 it was titled sick individuals and
sick populations and what Rose called to
our attention was that there is a there
are differences between thinking about
disease or development at the level of
individuals versus the level of
populations he pointed out that one kind
of question uh to ask is why do some
individuals have uh higher blood
pressures than others these are again
London civil servants this nice gaussian
distribution of blood pressure but
another kind of question question was uh
quite a quite a different uh sort of
question why is blood pressure higher in
some populations such as London civil
servants than in other populations like
Kenyan uh
Nomads so two fundamentally different
kinds of questions now clearly the
herzman kind of question was the latter
Clyde was fundamentally interested in
differences between populations and why
those differences occurred where they
came came from their ideology their
Origins the other type of question uh
why do some individuals have higher
blood pressure than others is a voice
kind of question uh because I have been
uh fundamentally interested in the
breadth of these kinds of distributions
of biological phenomena and why they
differ so profoundly among uh children
of different
groups so now let me uh fill in the
other part of this convergence which is
uh just a brief synopsis of uh the work
that I've been doing over the last uh 15
to 20 years so my work uh began with
this uh single most well-replicated
finding in all of Child Health Services
Research which is that when you look at
the distribution of morbidity and
illness within childhood populations
represented by this whole array of
children here that you find that that
distribution is highly non-random in
character it's very uneven it's it's not
distributed uh evenly across the
childhood population and in fact there
is a subset of children usually
constituting about 15 to 20% uh of kids
about one in five represented by these
darker green little figures who are
responsible for well over half of the
biomedical and psychiatric morbidities
within that population and in addition
uh utilize well over half of the health
care uh within that population so a
tremendous unevenness in the
distribution of morbidity now the public
health implications of that finding are
obvious if we could find something out
about what's going on with these
children we would be potentially able to
address uh well over half of the
morbidity the illness the chronic
disease within that uh population of
kids well it turns out that when you
begin to study those children those one
in five who have this disproportionate
rate of illness
it turns out that there are some of the
same things that you've been hearing
about all day that emerge these are
children who come primarily from lower
sces uh families they are children who
are in families that are uh chaotic who
are experiencing major adversity in
their lives uh they come from uh
families that uh have a great deal of
chaos and Mobility uh so there's a lot
of stress in the lives of these children
who have this disproportionate uh
morbidity so our work began by asking
why why would this be why why would
there be all of the children within
these populations have stressors and
adversities in their lives but why would
there be this subgroup who have this
tremendously increased uh rate of
morbidity and the way that we began to
address that question was to say let's
bring children into highly standardized
highly scripted situations that demand
things of them that are Chang
challenging not so challenging that they
run out of the room and go back to their
mom but things that are that are
challenging at the emotional level
interpersonal level cognitively so we
brought children into these
circumstances put them in front of a
previously unknown unknown examiner and
asked them to do a series of
ecologically valid but challenging uh
mildly stressful tasks and while we did
that we indexed uh two of the the
principal uh brain uh uh circuitries uh
for that are responsible for stress
response and those are uh the
corticotropin releasing hormone system
which uh is centered here in the
hypothalamus which is responsible for
communicating with the pituitary the
release of Act and the secretion of
cortisol which of course has profound
effects on blood pressure glucose
regulation and so on the other system is
the one that is centered in this little
uh uh nucleus here in the brain stem
called the locus cerius which through
dopaminergic pre uh projections up to
the hypothalamus ignites the whole fight
ORF flight response that we're all
familiar with the dilating of our eyes
the tremulousness of our hands the
sweaty uh Palms that we've all
experienced under conditions of duress
um and
challenge now what we found in study
after study really was that when we
looked at uh the distribution the
frequency distribution of responses
Within These two systems this one
happens to show uh pre-ejection period
which is a measure of the sympathetic uh
branch of the autonomic nervous system
you can see that there is a broad uh
distribution uh also very normal in in
uh character uh with some children at
the very high end some children at the
very low end and many many children in
the middle these are the children that
we became acutely interested in because
of what happened to those children when
we then looked at their outcomes in
epidemiologic uh study designs so let me
show you that I'm going to show you one
representative finding from one of
what's now probably 15 to 20 uh findings
of this kind uh that we've been able to
uh uh accumulate over the last couple of
Decades of work so this was uh work by
one of uh our post-doctoral fellow is
actually a global scholar within sear
Yelena ovich who's now an assistant
professor at Stanford uh she was looking
at the rate of external externalizing
behavior problems among children from
families with low versus high marital
conflict and she via this lab uh uh
procedure divided that sample of
children into those with low autonomic
nervous system reactivity and those with
high autonomic nervous system reactivity
the high being the ones in that little
uh red circle on the previous graph so
here's what we find over and over again
we find that the children the 80 85% of
kids within our uh laboratory uh that
have low autonomic or adrenocortical
reactivity basically have very little
increase in uh behavior problems and
other forms of uh of of morbidity within
childhood uh under conditions of high
marital stress it's almost as if they're
kind of indifferent to whether their
parents are fighting or Not by contrast
to that the children who were these kids
who had this extreme reactivity in the
laboratory uh setting uh had a very
different pattern they had the highest
rates of behavior problems and other
maladaptive outcomes under conditions of
high marital uh conflict but when they
were being raised in families with low
marital conflict something that we
hadn't expected uh showed up which was
that these kids didn't just come back to
kind of normal levels of their of their
peers and the 80% who were low in
reactivity but they actually went past
them and had the lowest rates of
morbidity of any of the children uh in
the sample so over and over again we
have found these uh findings where we
see that the high reactivity children
have either the worst of outcomes or the
best of outcomes depending upon the
character of the social environment in
which they find themselves uh being
reared now our interpretation of this
has been that this represents a kind of
differential neurobiological
susceptibility to social context we have
as you've heard uh used uh a kind of
shorthand for this referring uh to the
kids in the 80% with low reactivity and
these kind of indifferent responses to
psychosocial stressors uh using the
Swedish U idiomatic expression mcross
Barn which means dandelion child and the
swedes literally mean by this a kid like
a dandelion who will grow almost
wherever you want to plant plant that
child and we coined this uh you know
Swedish
neologism or kab barn or Orchid child to
describe the kids who like the Orchid
have can have extraordinarily wonderful
outcomes but are highly dependent
dependent upon the character uh the
nuanced character of the social
environment in which they are being
reared so we began to think about these
as uh Orchid and dandelion children now
we have uh now replicated these kind of
findings using uh genetic means of of
separating children rather than
laboratory measures of stress reactivity
this is work by Nikki Bush and Nancy
Adler and I at UCSF uh it shows uh
sorry it shows the uh fall chronic uh
daily cortisol level the level of stress
that children are experiencing in school
as a function of low versus high family
income basically a measure of
socioeconomic status and here you see
the same phenomenon that children who
had a brain derived neurotrophic factor
polymorphism that resulted in a a veine
to methine amino acid substitution uh
they had either uh the worst outcomes
the highest cortisol secretion or the
lowest outcomes so here again uh the
dandelion and uh the
Orchid and in fact over the last several
years we have accumulated findings at a
whole variety of different biological
levels differing uh tremendously in
scale and complex
that range from uh chromatin
modification by epigenetic marks through
uh G by interactions like the one I
showed you uh from Nikki Bush uh through
the CR and Locus culus norepinephrine
systems that I originally started with
through Behavior Uh and temperament the
work of J bski and on up into the uh the
human a metagenome so at every level
that we've had a chance to look at us
and others we have found found evidence
for this kind of crossover interaction
that is so interesting to us in
differentiating kids who differ in their
sensitivity to social context and social
adversity oh and I just wanted to show
you the last time I talked about this a
woman came up came rushing up afterwards
and said I was born in the former
Czechoslovakia and I uh I survived and I
thrived and I'm now here in Canada and
I'm strong and in fact I am a dandelion
child and then she showed me her foot
which which shows a dandelion and carped
tude on her on her
foot so Clyde's work which began with
this uh focus on uh the environment uh
the the really the physical environment
of these blighted Societies in Eastern
Europe and moved uh quickly into a focus
on childhood uh converged then with my
work on
children within social groups and the uh
discernment of these Orchid and
dandelion
children the convergence resulted for
Clyde and me in this synthesis it was a
proposal that maybe children are
actually the differentially susceptible
demographic subgroup within human
populations if we think about this not
at the individual level like I tend to
think about it but rather at the
population level like Clyde tends to
think about it maybe children are in
fact the
analoges of the dandelion children
within my samples of school AG uh
children maybe the childhood population
actually functions as the orchids within
uh broader human populations now the
implications of that if there were
evidence for it would be would be big
because it would mean that these
children are going to be be sensitive
not only to uh noxious toxic
environments but they would also be more
sensitive to positive encouraging
nurturant environments and the policy
implications of that kind of a shift
that we see with those dandelion
children that go from the the worst
outcomes to the best outcomes just
depending upon the kind of uh social
environment in which they find
themselves is a big uh shift so let I'm
asking you to think with me for just a
moment now about uh three different
aspects of this hypothesis that that
children are in fact uh the
differentially susceptible demographic
subgroup within human populations let's
think together about the biological
plausibility of that hypothesis a bit
about what epidemiologic evidence there
might exist and finally a little bit
about the implications for human
societies if that turned out to be a
valid hypothesis so we'll start now with
the with biological plausibility what we
would need to show to uh provide some
evidence for biological plausibility
would be at least two kinds of phenomena
one would be uh that there would be
biological sources of plasticity and
susceptibility within the lives of
children that are unusual relative to
those of older uh adolescents and adults
and secondly that there might be
increased exposures among uh children
relative to uh adults and older uh
individuals
so one one source of biological
plausibility is this tremendous neuronal
and bl brain circuitry development uh
that is a source of plasticity this just
shows uh the same little guy over uh
several months of time and shows the
corresponding changes in cortical
neurons and synapse developments uh that
are happening over this same period of
time you've heard uh throughout the day
especially early in the morning about
these huge changes that are happening in
the the infant brain uh there is this
exuberant uh profusion of the
development of neurons and connections
synapses between neurons uh followed by
a a pruning back and a selection of
those synapses and neurons over time
this is a a huge source of plasticity in
the early life of young
children secondly you've also heard
about uh Gene environment interplay as a
source of elasticity and we know and as
you heard from Marlo's talk that uh DNA
is not just DNA in a DNA double helix it
is in fact if you uncoil it from the
chromosome is uh like beads on a string
the DNA is wrapped around these uh
histone proteins that together form a
nucleosome and the tightness or the
looseness of that structure disallows or
allows the transcription of that uh DNA
so we have both in the epig genome all
of these different chemical tags DNA
methylation the histone proteins can be
acetylated methylated and so on so there
are these epig genomic sources of
variation and there are there is
transcriptional regulation that happens
at the genomic level as well in the form
of single nucleotide polymorphisms
splice variants micrornas and so on and
together these two
can alter gene expression which in turn
Alters Behavior development and risk
which in turn is responsible for these
beautiful and amazing differences in
phenotype that we see among uh human
children both in terms of physical
phenotype but also in terms of character
of of risk uh their liabilities their
strengths and so
on the other uh aspect of biological
plausibility is whether there might be
greater environmental exposures among
children and we do know that when we
look at the mean water intake for
example at per on a per kilo uh basis as
a function of uh age we find that there
is this uh tremendous increase in per
kilo water consumption uh among young
children infants drink seven times as
much water as the average adult and we
know as well that uh young children are
famous for having this kind of
impermeable relationship with the
physical environment there's lots of
eating dirt and worms and uh stuff like
that um we also know that as children uh
grow that they encounter uh much more
deeply and complexly uh the uh the
social environment in which they uh in
which they live so uh as children go
from infants to toddlers on through into
uh presol school age and into Primary
School there is this huge profusion of
contact uh with uh the social
environment so tremendously greater
increases in exposures to both the
physical environment and the social
environment so let's go on now to
epidemiologic evidence if you think with
me about this for just a moment what
would we need to see to have
epidemiologic evidence for uh this
hypothesis well first we would want to
see uh that there are environment
exposures involving both children and
adults it's remarkable how few uh
studies there are out there that look at
uh either an intervention or some other
form of environmental exposure in both
children and adults and measure the same
outcome but that is one Criterion for
evaluating uh this hypothesis the second
is that we should show increased risk
under conditions of threat the the
dandelion children within our sub
samples show this kind of phenomenon of
increased risk under conditions of
threat but thirdly there should also be
evidence of diminished risk under
conditions of protection this is not
good enough by itself this has to be
there as well so let me offer you just
uh four snapshots of epidemiologic
evidence that this may in fact uh be
true first of all um
if we look sadly at the leukemia
incidents by age at the atomic bomb
exposures in Hiroshima uh and Nagasaki
Japan the Hiroshima individuals shown in
the black and the Nagasaki individuals
shown in the hatched uh parts of this
graph this shows uh the years after
exposure so this is the time of the
atomic uh exposure this is time going
forward and this is on this axis the age
at the time uh of the uh Atomic uh bomb
explosion and then on the third axis
coming out of the out of the uh surface
here is uh excess risk uh in uh the high
do group and what you can see is that
the highest and earliest risk of
leukemia is among exposed children so
here was a uniform exposure Within These
two uh cities in Japan uh clear evidence
that children were the more susceptible
to the develop of leukemia in the period
following uh the
exposure secondly uh Sheldon Cohen's
work um fascinating work where he looks
at childhood social conditions uh then
looks at uh young adults inoculates them
in the nose with a rhinovirus and looks
to see whether they develop an infection
or not and his work has nicely shown
that the number of years parents have
owned their home as a measure of
socioeconomic status is a predictor of
the percentage of individuals who became
infected with the uh Rhino virus
introduced uh into their nose so those
who had long-term ownership of their
homes had much less in the way of
infection uh than those who had very
brief periods of home ownership but more
important to uh this argument is that
when he looks at the adjusted effect
sizes for associations between Parental
Home Ownership and susceptibility to
respiratory infection this is a graded
association with the most powerful
effect sizes among those who are young
in age relative to those who are older
in age and heading into adolescence so
again another uh piece of evidence for
increased risk under conditions of
thread now we need to show diminished
risk under conditions of protection as
well so here is an example of uh looking
at car's Dental Care carries prevalences
in communities with fluoridated versus
unfluoridated water in Australia UK
Canada Ireland New Zealand and the US
and the vertical axis here shows the
percent reduction in carries uh
prevalence by uh Age and what these data
show very clearly is that the highest
effect sizes are among the very young
and this diminishes over time so here's
an example of the protection of oral
health by fluoridating the community
wall water that is greatest in the young
and and more minimal in the
old and finally uh here is an experiment
this is the uh the moving to opportunity
experiment that occurred in five US
cities uh the effect of these
interventions on anxiety and depression
in parents uh and children uh it was a
three-part a three arm experiment there
was a control group that basically got
nothing there was a group uh that had
housing vouchers so that they were able
to move if they felt that they needed to
and then there was an experimental group
that was actively encouraged to move and
and facilitated the move to
neighborhoods that would be moves up in
terms of socioeconomic uh status uh and
and mobility and what you can see here
is that when you compare the effect on
children relative to the effect on
parents that both the housing voucher
only group and the experimental group
showed greater effects in the children
than it did uh on the parents so the
greatest benefits of both the
experimental and the housing voucher
interventions were uh greatest in
children so finally what are the
implications for human
societies well I think the implication
is what we've been hearing about all day
that societies have an obligation a
moral obligation uh an imperative to
provide a singular attentiveness to the
welfare uh of
children uh we are not doing that and
this is uh similar to some of the uh
slides that you've seen earlier today
this is from the oecd uh a report called
doing better for our children it shows
the percentage of children living in
poor
households and here are Canada and the
United States uh very high uh prevalence
rates of poverty with within
childhood uh this is a report from uh
Unicef on child well-being in Rich C
countries they looked at various aspects
of children's relationships the family
structure things such as the percentage
of children uh living in single parent
homes family relationships uh the
proportion of children who uh report
that their parents spend time just
talking to them peer relationships
percentage of 11 13 and 15 15year olds
who report uh their peers as kind and
helpful uh and again here we find this
is a standardized score uh above and
below the median and here we find Canada
and the United States down in the uh
very low reaches of child uh relational
well-being finally uh we might think
that we would reward provide greater
remuneration and reward for those
serving the youngest of children
because of this phenomenon this is an
approximation of the growth in size and
complexity of the brain over these first
few years of life through adolescence
you can see that by about the age of
nine in terms of uh size and complexity
the brain uh has probably reached uh its
uh Zenith and you would think that
because of this because of this
intensive brain growth uh during this
early period of life that this would be
the period where we would want to place
the the greatest investment and the
greatest uh amount of uh remuneration
and of course as you well know uh it is
just uh the opposite of that uh what we
find is that uh preschool teachers make
hardly anything kindergarten teachers a
little more and so on up the scale uh to
University professors I'm not advocating
U the
uh go on record saying I'm not
advocating a transfer of salaries here
but uh you would think that we would at
least as societies establish a parody
between those who are teaching our
youngest and most plastic and and
vulnerable and uh and uh susceptible uh
young people uh in this uh uh uh age
range it's particularly compelling this
graph in light of uh the the findings of
Raj chedy an economist at Harvard who
found that if you look at the 20
children who have either a really great
kindergarten teacher or uh you know a
kind of blah average kindergarten
teacher that the the the increase in
value to Society of having 20 children
receive a good kindergarten teacher for
uh the one year of kindergarten is about
132,000 dollars a year and I can
guarantee you there are no kindergarten
teachers in North America who are uh
making that but maybe they
should so I will end here and I I want
to tell you just a very brief story uh
Max Dupri uh who is a business leader
and author of several books on
leadership uh wrote in his book
leadership is an art about his
granddaughter Zoe who was born
prematurely weighing just one pound the
neonatologist who initially saw Zoe said
that she had about a 5 to 10% chance of
living three days she was in a neonatal
ICU with multiple tubes and monitors
when Dupri and his wife came for a first
first visit to complicate matters
further Zoe's father had jumped ship the
month before she was born realizing this
A very wise neonatal nurse took the
grandfather aside and gave him his his
instructions which were as
follows for the next several months at
least you are the surrogate father I
want you to come to the hospital every
day to visit Zoe and when you come I
would like you to rub her body and her
legs and arms with the tip of your
finger and while you're caressing her
you should tell her over and over again
how much you love her because she has to
be able to connect your voice to your
touch I think that what made Clyde such
a brilliant and memorable leader was his
remarkable capacity for connecting voice
and touch he was able somehow to link
his heartfelt and outspoken passion for
better more just Society ities with his
ways of being and doing in the world
both professionally and personally he
was an extraordinary synthesis of heart
voice touch and action and his Devotion
to children's lives will not soon be
forgotten by any of us thank
you